nous proposons donc de mieux rémunérer
les enseignants cours de ses premières
années déterminantes comme la cac
le parti libéral propose de bonifier le
salaire de départ des enseignants au
québec les enseignantes et enseignants
qui entreprendront leur première année
d'enseignement seront rémunérés selon
les chenaux sceptre commencé sa carrière
de prof à l'échelon 7 actuellement
ça voudrait dire passer de 45 à 53 me
une augmentation de 8000 dollars
toutefois une telle augmentation ne
ferait que rattraper en partie le
salaire qu'on donne aux nouveaux
enseignants ailleurs au pays
la dernière étude de statistique canada
démontrent ceci 53000 d'horreur c'est
moins que le salaire de départ donné à
un enseignant du manitoba et de la
saskatchewan
il y a 4 1 53 milles c'est légèrement
plus élevé que la moyenne canadienne de
2014 2015
la proposition de wisques à bonifier
salaire de départ les enseignants qui
ont déjà dépassé l'échelon 7
n'obtiendrait pas d'augmentation par
contre en commençant à l'échelon 7 les
plus jeunes vont pouvoir atteindre le
sommet de l'échelle salariale plus
rapidement on prouve qu'il est quoi qui
touche le maximum gagne actuellement 80
de 1500 $ ça c'est environ ce le gagner
un enseignant de la nouvelle écosse il y
a 4 1 et c'est beaucoup moins qu'en
ontario
le sommet de l'échelle était de 94 1600
dollars en 2015
[Musique]